IN CONTEMPT AND IMPEACH.
>> Laura: TO IMPEACH
CHRISTOPHER WRAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE NOT MESSING AROUND.
>> Laura: THIS AFTERNOON THE
FBI AND DOJ CAVED, A GOVERNMENT
SOURCE SAYING THAT NUNES,
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY WERE
SHOWN A LARGELY UNREDACTED
VERSION OF THE MEMO.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS TONIGHT
THERE ARE STILL SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE UNDERLYING
INTEL AND THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
SOURCES USED TO INITIATE THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
HERE TO REACT TO TODAY'S DEVELOP
MUCH, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN OF OHIO.
CONGRESSMAN, ALL IS WELL, RIGHT?
THEY COUGHED UP THE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION, THE TWO-PAGE
DOCUMENT AFTER THE COMMENT LAST
NIGHT BY NUNES ON THE SHOW.
>> A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
>> A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTIO
DIRECTION.
THERE WERE STILL REDACTIONS IN
IT.
SOMETIMES I GO TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL, WHY IS IT THAT
FOLKS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GET TO SEE UNREDACTED
THINGS BUT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE OF THIS
GREAT COUNTRY CAN'T SAVE --
CAN'T SEE THEM?
IF YOU DO BECAUSE THEY SAY THAT
YOU LEAKED.
>> WHAT I KNOW IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT ANSWERS AND YOU
CAN'T GET ANSWERS TO IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT DEAL WITH THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL LIBERTIES IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: WHY DOES CHRISTOPHER
WRAY, EXCUSE ME, PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE STILL HAVE THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCE?
>> SAME ISSUE.
THEY ARE SO COMPROMISED BOB
MUELLER SHOOK THEM OFF HIS TEAM.
BUT THEY STILL HAVE SECURITY
CLEARANCE AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS CAN'T SEE DOCUMENTS.
WE HAD A NEW POINT PERSON OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
JOHN LAUSCH IS THE NEW POINT
PERSON.
THAT WE ARE ENTITLED TO.
HE COMES IN TO TALK TO
MR. MEADOWS AND I YESTERDAY
ALONG WITH OTHER LAWYERS, ASKING
FOUR SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
ONCE THE NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS?
I SAID WHAT IS THE STANDARD FOR
DETERMINING HOW THE REDUCTIONS
ARE DONE AND WHAT ARE THE STEPS
AND HOW THE PROCESS WORKS?
I DON'T KNOW.
LEADS THE IMPORTANT QUESTION,
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO THE
DOCUMENTS?
I DON'T KNOW.
MY ATTITUDE IS LIKE DEVIN NUNES.
IF THINGS DON'T CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY, I AM TALKING DAYS,
NOT WEEKS OR MONTHS.
IF THEY DON'T CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY THAN IMPEACHMENT
AND CONTEMPT AND RESIGNATIONS
SHOULD ALL BE ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE WE ARE TIRED OF IT.
MORE IMPORTANT, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF IT.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU SAY
IMPEACHMENT, RESIGNATION,
FIRING, WHO ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
FIRING, WHO ARE WE TALKING ABOU
ABOUT?
>> TALKING ABOUT THE GUYS WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE RUNNING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
JEFF SESSIONS AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CHARGE.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO GIVE US
INFORMATION.
NEVER FORGET THE UNDERLYING
ISSUE.
THEY TOOK AN OPPOSITION RESEARCH
DOCUMENT, DRESSED IT UP AND MADE
IT LOOK LIKE LEGITIMATE
INTELLIGENCE, TOOK IT TO A
SECRET COURT TO GET A SECRET
WARRANT TEST BY A FELLOW CITIZEN
ASSOCIATE WITH THE TRIM CAMPAIGN
AND THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT
WHO PAID FOR THE DOCUMENT AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY IN THOSE
RENEWALS AND THE FISA COURT,
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT THAT
THE AUTHOR OF THE DOCUMENT,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HAD HIS
RELATIONSHIP TERMINATED WITH THE
FBI BECAUSE HE WENT AND LINKED
TO THE PRESS.
>> Laura: ACCORDING TO WHAT